-Performing "Fly Girl,"
give it up for FLO!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
-Let's go!
-♪ If you a fly girl,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
♪ See you're tellin' me
I'm pretty, but it's obvious ♪
♪ I don't need no man to tell me
where the party is ♪
♪ If you a fly girl,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
♪ See you're tellin' me
I'm pretty, but it's obvious ♪
♪ I don't need no man to tell me
where the party is ♪
-♪ Checklist, tick it off,
what you got? ♪
♪ Pricy,
so you better have a lot ♪
♪ A timepiece,
and it don't tick-tock ♪
♪ If you can't afford my time,
then just watch ♪
♪ Untouchable ♪
♪ Pretty too ♪
♪ Available ♪
♪ But not for you ♪
♪ Too sexy, way too fly ♪
♪ You get none of my ♪
-♪ I got plans tonight,
you ain't part of them ♪
♪ 'Cause my girls and I,
yeah, we all a ten ♪
♪ Know it's ladies night,
shout to all of them ♪
♪ Put your ones up in the sky ♪
-♪ If you a fly girl,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
♪ See you're tellin' me
I'm pretty, but it's obvious ♪
♪ I don't need no man to tell me
where the party is ♪
♪ If you a fly girl,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
♪ See you're tellin' me
I'm pretty, but it's obvious ♪
♪ I don't need no man to tell me
where the party is ♪
-♪ Oh, babe ♪
♪ Might leave you
waiting all day ♪
-♪ Waiting all day ♪
-♪ 'Cause all these
material things
are not enough to make me stay ♪
♪ You can't handle
all this nana ♪
♪ Talk, but I ain't
hearing nada ♪
♪ You're gonna have to try
a little harder ♪
♪ It takes a real one to hold me
down, down, down ♪
-♪ I got plans tonight,
you ain't part of them ♪
♪ 'Cause my girls and I,
yeah, we all a ten ♪
♪ Know it's ladies night,
shout to all of them ♪
♪ Put your ones up in the sky ♪
-♪ If you a fly girl,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
♪ See you're tellin' me
I'm pretty, but it's obvious ♪
♪ I don't need no man to tell me
where the party is ♪
♪ If you a fly girl,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
♪ See you're tellin' me
I'm pretty, but it's obvious ♪
♪ I don't need no man to tell me
where the party is ♪
-♪ If you a fly gal,
get your nails done ♪
♪ Get a pedicure,
get your hair did ♪
Ladies! Let's go!
♪ All my ladies,
go and get a outfit ♪
♪ And buy a new lace wig ♪
♪ Back up on the market,
better put in your bid ♪
♪ 'Cause when Missy
throw a party,
you can't find nowhere to sit ♪
-Big booty!
-♪ Booty, booty everywhere ♪
♪ I make all the dudes
throw their money in the air ♪
-♪ Money, money, money ♪
-♪ Me and all my girls,
yeah, we looking fabulair ♪
♪ Ooh, stop the track,
strike a pose, stop and stare ♪
♪ Wait, make it shake ♪
♪ All that cake ♪
♪ Let it bake ♪
♪ I know you wanna
see my body in a vase ♪
♪ Don't I still look like
Halle Berry in the face? ♪
♪ In the face ♪
♪ Missy and FLO,
we came to ride ♪
♪ We don't even need a guy
to tell us we fly ♪
♪ When the party get to poppin',
you know we inside ♪
-♪ So put your arms up
in the sky ♪
-♪ No, no, no, no, oh ♪
-♪ See you're telling me ♪
-♪ Where the party? ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
-♪ See you're tellin' me, oh ♪
-♪ Where the party ♪
♪ Why we got 'em so pressed? ♪
♪ Seeing us on top,
and it's got 'em all stressed ♪
♪ Fly girls, say "yes" ♪
♪ Tryin' to compete,
but it ain't a contest ♪
♪ Why we got 'em so pressed? ♪
♪ Say "yes" ♪
♪ Fly girls, say "yes" ♪
♪ Tryin' to compete,
but it ain't a contest ♪
-[ Laughs ]
FLO, I like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!